IAN HUTCHINSON: Let's
just finish this
off by cleaning up this
plot and saving it.
In the first case, I don't
have any labels on my axes.
That's bad.
Let me put some
labels on my axes.
X-label is the way you do this.
And in this case I have a
very simple label that I want.
And the same thing,
presumably for Y-label.
That will at least
put some labels on.
Aren't they horribly small?
But they are there.
Now, I want to improve
this plot in general.
Let me point out another
thing that I want to do.
I don't want to have
hold on permanently,
so let me put hold off
after the second plot.
And that's going to avoid
difficulties in the future.
So I'm just going to save that.
Now in order to improve
the size of the labels
and so forth that's
involved with this,
there are a number
of things one can do.
And in general, I'm going to
do this for many of my plots.
And so what I want
to do is I want
to illustrate the fact
that my script-- which
is called fitting.m,
can call another script.
And it can call as
many scripts as I like.
The script I'm going to call,
I have in my editor already.
It's called plot defaults.
Plot defaults.m.
And here are some
mysterious calls
that you will find out
only by reading the help
files in general.
By the way, in Octave
there's all kinds of help
that you can find out by
typing things like, help.
But in general it's more
useful usually to use doc.
And so we could do
doc, let's say a plat
and it would then
bring me to a place
in the documentation, where
the documentation for plot
is described.
MathLab has got
its own help system
and you can use that to
look up various things.
I could do doc of,
let's say, set,
and it will show
me what these set
commands that are in this
file plot defaults are doing.
The syntax is
complicated and it's not
worth us dwelling
on it at the moment.
Let me just explain
what it's going to do.
First of all it's going to
set the default access label
font size to be bigger, 20.
Second thing it's
going to do is it's
going to make the width of
the lines of the axes two
instead of one because
the axes on these plots
may well be better
if they're thicker.
In general these plots tend to
come up with rather thin lines.
That's useful generally, but the
most useful thing to fix these
plots, and to get the labelling
to be a decent size turns out
to be to shrink the size of
the plot leave the font size
the same.
So what this command
does is it basically
sets the paper units, the paper
orientation, and the paper size
to be three inches by four
inches, height versus width.
And then it sets the paper
position in such a way
that we aren't
writing off the paper.
As I said, all of this is subtle
and you wouldn't necessarily
want to know all
the details of this.
I'll happily make this
file available to you.
But all I have to do
in order to execute
those commands in that
file, plot defaults,
is write the command
plot defaults.
And I'm going to do that
before my first plot.
So plot defaults
should read in that
file that I was just
looking at, this file,
and execute the commands in it.
Notice, by the way,
comments, very important.
Because these commands
are mysterious,
I put some commentary
to remind you
what they're supposed to
be doing next to them,
and the way the
comment is defined
is by having a percent line
at the beginning of the line,
or actually anywhere else
in the line for that matter.
OK.
Let's save this new
file and run it again.
And lo and behold it's run.
Probably-- I may not have
several of the defaults right
because I've been doing a
number of things in this Octave
session.
If I get tired of
this Octave session--
I've run 25 different commands
on it, it's telling me--
and I want to
start a fresh, it's
sometimes helpful to start
a new, fresh session.
I can do this very
straightforwardly,
we're just saying, exit, and
then starting over again.
That's one way to be sure you've
got a nice, fresh session.
One of the nicest
things about Octave
is it actually still remembers
what your commands were,
even though you've
got a new session.
So here's what the plot
looks like, in the case
when I run it with plot
defaults and executed before any
of other plotting commands.
So the plot defaults needs to
happen before anything else.
And now what you see is
much better, much bigger
at any rate labels on the
axes, et cetera, et cetera.
Things aren't perfect.
There's a little y is crashed
with the x there, but anyway.
You can tweak around with
those to your heart's content.
If this were fine, my final
plot, what I wanted to save,
one of the ways I
could save it would
be to do some kind of screen
capture on this window
that I'm plotting it in.
That would give me a rather
cumbersome and not very pretty
plot.
There is another way of
plotting, of saving this plot.
And that is to use
the command print.
So print is actually
printing out the plotting.
One has to tell print
what format one wants.
Supposing I want EPS
format, I could say D EPS.
And suppose that I know what
file I want to save it into,
I could, for example, write
fitted.EPS, like that.
So this tells it to print out
this plot into an EPS file,
which is then named fitted.EPS.
Let's see what happens.
Nothing obvious,
except that if I now
look in the directory, which in
Octave I can do by typing LS,
there is a file
called fitted EPS.
I don't want to get out
of my Octave session.
I'm in the same directory here.
Here it is, fitted EPS.
Let's have a look at that
file using ghost view,
and there it is.
This is now a good quality
file that I might be
proud to show to my professor.
It's actually not in color.
That's because I use EPS.
I think it's EPS C for color.
Let me try it.
Let's run that again and now
look at it again, and see,
yes, it's color.
Now it's color.
So that's how to get
a plot and to save
it looking halfway decent.
And that's where we'll end.